[Musique]
avec moi sur ce plateau mélanie poker
bons soirs où ça cette semaine a lancé
les commémorations de la première guerre
mondiale 11 novembre de nombreuses
communes célébreront les 100 ans de la
fin du conflit mondial à 14,18 une
période de l'histoire qu inspire aussi
les artistes mélanie votre coup de coeur
de la semaine est un ouvrage pour
enfants la guerre en mille morceaux
raconte l'histoire du soldat macha un
jeune homme envoyé au front dès la
mobilisation en août 14
ce soldat machin de son nom civil
maturana pas existé alain serres son
créateur a choisi d'en faire un anonyme
un soldat parmi les 73 millions
mobilisés durant le conflit
le soldat machin c'est un soldat moyens
qui ressemble à tous les autres
à l'époque la fin de la france rurale il
est bien sûr est issu d'un petit village
et comme le raconte la légende le cliché
je dirais bien il était en plein champ
en train de travailler quand le tocsin a
sonné je suis donc ce combat au
quotidien
oui avec subtilité alain cern cachard
rien pourtant de l'auteur de l'horreur
du conflit les tranchées le froid
intense de l'hiver la chaleur de l'été
les gaz la peur les assauts alors l'idée
à grégory n'est bien sûr pas d'effrayer
mais de faire comprendre l'intensité du
conflit
ce qu'ont vécu nos ancêtres alors sert à
travailler avec zaho zayouna eu voilà je
le prononce doigts pour les
illustrations et plusieurs planches sont
accompagnées de photographies sur ces
photographies des objets d'époque une
cinquantaine alors tous ont été
rassemblées par l'auteur lui-même
alain serres au fil des années on y
trouve un clairon défigureront plomb une
lanterne et à l'image un stylo créé par
un poilus dans les tranchées à l'aide de
deux doubles collées entre elles
j'ai exclu tous les objets qui étaient
strictement militaire c'est pas du tout
le sens de ma petite collection
je voulais qu'il y ait du sens de la vie
on peut les ombres humaine derrière
derrière chacun de ces objets voilà un
autre moyen d'apprendre sur le conflit
si les deux soldats de l'époque ont tous
disparu leurs objets témoignent du
quotidien l'histoire de mathurin est à
lire dans la guerre en mille morceaux
publié aux éditions rue du monde
merci mélanie on vous retrouve juste
après ce journal pour un magazine 7,8
culture entièrement consacrée au
souvenir de la guerre de 14 18